The second design alternative gave concurrency but
at the cost of exposing the business
logic, and the third design alternative that
I'm going to explain to you, is going to
correct that, it's using session bean with
entity bean. The idea is that, we're going to
associate it with each client session, a
session facade, it's a design pattern that allows
you to construct a session and associate it
with a particular client. So, for instance, in
this case, this session facade corresponds to servelet
1, which corresponds to the client that it
is serving similarly this session facade, serving client
number 2. And as in the first design,
what you see is that the web container
contains only the servelet and the presentation logic that
is associated with that particular servlet. Now
the business logic, is moved back into
the EJB container, and it sits with the session facade. And we still have the
data access objects implemented using the entity
beam concept that I mentioned in the
second design alternative. So, the session facade
is worrying about all the data access needs
of its associated business logic. Similarly, this session
facade is worrying about all the data access
needs of this business logic, and what the
session facade is going to do is, it's going to
form out the data access requests corresponding to
the business logic associated with this session. So,
there's an opportunity, again, to exploit parallelism because
you can form out parallel requests to multiple
entity beans. That are handling the data access
to different portions of the database and similar
to the second, design alternative, we're going to structure
this database to be at whatever level of
granularity that we think is the right one.
So this entity bean may be responsible for
an individual role. Or a cluster of rows, and so on. And that way, we can have
the granularity that we want for parallel access so
that the business logic can be served in parallel,
and at the same time, we have moved the
business logic back into the EJB container. So, the
business logic is not exposed outside the corporate network.
And we have a couple of choices of how
we want to structure the session bean with the enity
bean. Now the whip container is going to use RMI. A
remote interface in the distributed object framework
of Java. In order to communicate with
the business logic, and the session facade
is going to communicate with the entity bean either
using RMI. In that case, the interaction
between the session facade and the entity bean
is very similar to the interaction between
the servlet and the session facade. That is,
it'll use RMI. Or, we can choose to
construct the interface between the session facade and
the entity bean, using local interfaces. And the
reason why we may want to choose one or
the other, using the RMI allows us to,
sort of, keep this entity bean wherever we
want in the network. On the other hand,
if we chose the local option, what we're seeing
is that we will co locate the entity beans in the same EJB container as the
business logic and the session facade. The advantage
of doing that, is that because it is local,
we don't have to incur network communication, in
order to go and fetch the data from the
entity bean. The entity bean, of course, has
to fetch it from the database servers, but once
it fetches it from the database servers, it
doesn't have to go through the network in order
to give it to the business logic if
you're using local interfaces. So that's another bifurcation within
this design alternative. We can choose to construct
this portion of the application using remote interface or
local interface. And the prose of this structure is
in some sense getting the best of both worlds.
We're not exposing the business logic. Which
was the virtue of the first design alternative,
and we're also getting concurrency through the data
access object encoded as entity beans. So you
get the concurrency and the fact that the
business logic is within the corporate network. Both
of those good features are available in this
design alternative. Now is there a con well,
we are incurring additional network access in order
to do the servers that we want for
the data access, and that can be mitigated
by call locating, the entity bean, and the
session facade in the same EJB container. So
that's a choice that you can make. So
these are the 3 design alternatives that we
talked about. One is a coarse grain session
bean alternative. The second is a finer
grained data access object alternative, and the
third is sort of putting together the first two. Putting the session bean as a
facade. To actually access the data access
objects, which are encoded in entity bean
so that you can get concurrency. Notice
that in talking about these different design alternatives,
we're only talking about how to break up
that application, the logic of that application, which consists
of presentation to the client, business logic that
has to do with decisions that this enterprise has
to make in order to service this request,
and database access in order to get the data
that is needed in order to do the work that is involved. In serving up the needs
of a particular client. Lots of things that are needed in addition to writing
about the application logic itself. And those
are things like security, persistence, and so
on. The power of object technology is the fact that So that's the
thing that I wanted to start with and I wanted to give you the different
design alternatives that exist in structuring these complex
services using the object technology to reuse components
instructed in structuring complex applications.